we
are breaking into programming to go live
to the israeli knesset in west jerusalem
where
a vote is happening right now on a new
coalition government these are live
pictures
from the knesset in west jerusalem this
is
an historic moment uh
could see the unseating of israel's
longest serving
prime minister benjamin netanyahu sent
to the opposition
standing by for us we have al jazeera's
harry falcon
harry just run us through what's
happening now
sorry just as you were coming to me
there the
it seems that one of the members of the
united arab list which is the
palestinian-israeli party which
has been supporting the change block
four members in the knesset there was
some
discussion uh earlier on in the day uh
that the um that one of those members
was unhappy with some of the
details of the coalition agreement and
literally as you're asking me that
question
the second roll call was asked he'd been
absent
uh said alharumi in the first roll call
in the second roll call uh what i just
heard in my ear at least was that he had
abstained
now if that is the case that means that
it's
60 of the 120 seats
voting in favor of the government not
the slender
one seat majority 61 to 59 that they had
been promising
uh they had um 60 59 i'm just being told
by
my colleague as well so that's confirmed
that it's 61
59 is what they were expecting what they
were looking for
one of the members of the
palestinian-israeli party
voting with the change bloc has decided
to abstain that makes it 60-59
that could potentially leave things open
to some kind of legal challenge because
this would be the first time
that an israeli government had been
voted through on a
plurality rather than absolute majority
uh so this is a last minute hitch
whether it's decisive or not we don't
yet know but it's extraordinary that at
the last minute
uh this extra obstacle this extra
roadblock has
appeared before the change block okay
harry we'll um get you a standby there
for us while we listen in to what's
happening there in the knesset
members of knesset please be seated
59 again
[Applause]
please be done please remain
calm i understand the joy but please
please
the method has voted
the 36th government
so as you can see there these are
pictures from inside
the israeli knesset where voters just
happened
on bringing in a new coalition
government as we heard there
60 votes 4 59 against
and surprise abstention
uh let's bring in al jazeera's harry
falsett
terry just walk us through what's
happening there
well uh as i say this one member of the
united arab list he was unhappy
about some of the details to do with one
of the key things that mansur abbas the
leader of that party
had demanded in return for his support
for this
this coalition that would oust benjamin
netanyahu to do with demolitions of
bedouin
structures and and homes in the mega
desert in israel's
south uh he had indicated earlier in the
day
that he may make trouble for the
government that he may vote
against it in in various arenas but the
preponderance of what they were
communicating
was that he would at least vote in favor
of the government and they came out of a
meeting
ahead of this session beginning uh the
eight leaders of the eight constituent
parts of this coalition
saying that they had a government this
now throws things
at least into some doubt it's not
necessarily
the end of things for them potentially
they could get through on a slender as
margin is
60 to 59 there are two abstentions uh
one from the
the joint list the the mainly
palestinian-israeli joint list which was
always going to be outside the coalition
another abstention more crucially uh who
who was expected to vote
in favor but speaking to one of the uh
one of the the party members of uh
naftali bennett the new prime minister
designate
uh when we were talking earlier in the
week about strategies and
potentials he was saying that if
they don't get the full majority the 61
out of 120 seats
in the israeli parliament the knesset
then it could allow
some kind of supreme court challenge
against it because this has never been
done before even a margin of slender
61-59 has never voted in an israeli
government before
now we're talking about not even an
absolute majority just
one seat and that seat not even being
decisive in terms of taking it to an
absolute majority so it is
another extraordinary twist in this tale
as for what's taken place
up until this point we heard from
naftali bennett who is supposed to be
prime minister
first under this new rotational deal
with his partner
yar lapid he was talking about a
government would come in and manage and
steward the economy
deliver for israelis after two and a
half years of stasis and political
crisis and not even a budget being able
to be passed
we heard from benjamin netanyahu who
listed his achievements as he saw them
put up obstacles very clearly
defining himself in opposition not just
to naftali bennett but to joe biden the
u.s
president so causing real ructions
between his outgoing he thought
and the u.s presidency in order to put a
big roadblock in the way
of naftali bennett in terms of the
question of iran
and the nuclear deal also promising that
he would do his utmost
to scupper this new government as
quickly as possible saying that he
would be back and if he was to go into
opposition he would do so with his back
straight
but this government would not last so
now we have to work and work out exactly
whether this government will indeed take
power
on this very slender majority i think
the chances are that it will
but that there could potentially be some
kind of challenge
to it so we'll we've got another few
very
uh interesting to say the least few days
ahead of us
yeah some uh last-minute twists and
turns uh which
can never be uh ruled out for now though
it does appear
uh that this new coalition
has uh has come into into government
uh that israel has a new prime minister
naftali bennett
uh and that for uh israel's longest
serving prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
is now in opposition i believe we are
going to listen in
no uh things seem to
basically be wrapping up there in in
nicknasset
harry just tell us how it is that we got
to this point
i mean we've had what four elections
since 2019 in israel how is it that even
right-wing parties no longer want to see
netanyahu
in power you would think they would be
somewhat or pretty much ideologically
aligned
yes but there are all sorts of things
conspiring against that
uh results taking place i mean if you
think back to after the first
election in this seemingly uh endless
cycle of election after election
uh after that first election the the
assumption was that yes exactly that the
right
would stay together that netanyahu felt
that he had
uh all of his ducks in a row all of his
right-wing coalition
partners there taking him above the
61-seat requirement for a coalition
government
but one of those right-wingers the party
belonging to avigdor lieberman who was
netanyahu's chief of staff
he decided last minute that no he was
going to jump ship
he wasn't going to support netanyahu and
that's what led to the first
redo election and then you look at other
former allies of his giron tsar
who used to be in the lakut uh he set up
a right-wing party ahead of this
election
uh specifically to unseat benjamin
netanyahu saying that he could no longer
be prime minister of israel at the time
when he had amassed so much of his
policy-making and so many of his
priorities
into his own personal uh private
fortunes
legal fortunes hurry i'm just gonna
pause you there because
uh naftali bennett is now speaking so
let's listen in
and and alternate prime minister in the
future
to withhold the laws of israel
to fulfill my duty as prime minister
and alternate prime minister and to
abide by
the rules of the knesset
okay that was uh natalie bennett there
pledging to uphold the laws
of israel uh coming in as the new
prime minister of that country
a tumultuous couple of years in israeli
politics
to say the least
their vote there getting to that point
of 64 this new coalition
59 against i think let's
speak now to
harry fawcett harry just remind us
uh of how different
ideologically the parties are that are
in this new coalition
sure yes i mean just to finish that
thought about naftali bennett he's
another
former close friend and ally of benjamin
netanyahu who himself
uh is now working to unseat him uh he
may have thanked him
at the beginning of his speech but he's
made it clear that that israel has been
toxified
by uh what he calls the the divisiveness
that that netanyahu has has
sort of perpetrated and so that's uh a
key reason why we have
come to this point that so many of
netanyahu's allies personally
within the knesset he's retained a lot
of his support
outside in the public at large but
within the knesset he's alienated so
many people that
we've seen uh these these members turn
against him at least
on this very very slim margin as for the
the change block that the new coalition
you're right it really does run the
gamut of israeli politics uh
to some that's its strength that it
shows that there is
uh will enough at least to get to this
stage
and to try to start managing a
company a a country start governing a
country that's been without
proper governance in in its terms in the
constituent parts of its
uh makeup they say that uh that
really israel has been languishing
without a proper budget without
real attention to the the key issues
that it requires
tackling for more than two years now
and so that's why they've come together
however
it does represent the far left in merits
in israeli terms at least
in the merits party uh the more
traditional left centrist left
in labor this new newish yeshateed party
sort of center center rightish center
leftish depending on your
definition of yahoo lapid all the way
through to
uh gideonsha and bennett who are very
much on the right further to the right
on some issues
than benjamin netanyahu and all of it
facilitated
by for the first time a
palestinian-israeli party
uh in the shape of the united arab list
led by mansur abbas
he was to some extent legitimized in the
in the eyes of the right wing in israel
at least
by the fact that he was also having
talks with benjamin netanyahu when he
had
the potential to try to form a
government a coalition after the last
election and so the very fact
that he had those talks meant that it
was no longer really
viable for netanyahu to criticize his
being part
of the makeup of an anti-netanyahu
coalition i mean of course he has tried
but the response is will you talk to him
why can't we
and so now there is this very very
broad-ranging coalition to some extent
it will be glued together
by the fact that netanyahu is railing
against it so hard
and that he is vowed to be the leader of
the opposition he's vowed to try to
bring it down
and come back to power sooner than you
think is what he said
in his speech earlier in the day and so
the threat of that could in some regard
keep them together
uh despite the obvious differences uh
and contradictions
within their makeup ideologically on the
the other branch of that is what they've
decided to do which is
really try to leave alone any
radioactive political
issues and ideologies that they might
have that would contradict the other
and try to be more of a sort of almost
technocratic managerial style government
which
obviously leaves major issues such as
the palestinians
just put to one side and
progress such as it was it hasn't really
been
under netanyahu and especially
facilitated by trump in recent years
uh is is on ice potentially again
because of the uh because of the mutual
contradictions of this government they
can't really
left-wingers and right-wingers come to a
reasonable accord
on how to approach an issue as difficult
as the conflict with the palestinians so
it may well just languish again
what they're selling though is that for
domestic israeli issues
they will be able to get on with the job
in a way that hasn't happened because of
the political status
in the last couple of years all right
thank you very much for that
update there harry fawcett
benjamin netanyahu has been